so here's the first story from National
Review Bragg's indictment even fails as
an indictment and this is a really great
piece from Andrew McCarthy who's like
what a disgrace it's always possible to
be surprised the indictment brought by
Manhattan's elected Democratic district
attorney Evan Bragg against Trump is
even worse than it imagined and here's
the important part he says he claims
that the 34 counts which warrant 136
years in prison are because Trump was
trying to conceal another crime
what is that other crime we don't know
because Bragg says he doesn't need to
present it it just is that's it
now here now look a lot of people orange
that's the crime well he's like Trump
lied in running for office it's like
about what I don't got to tell you
because it's not required and federal
campaign contributions was a crime and
they were like the feds did not charge
him with a crime over anything you have
no jurisdiction here he's doing it
anyway but here's what gets here's the
best part here's the satisfying icing on
the cake vox.com wrote yesterday the
dubious legal Theory at the heart of the
Trump indictment explained no one knows
if Donald Trump can be prosecuted for
the hush money payment the actual
original title of this article was Will
trump actually be convicted they don't
even think so it's fascinating to see
CNN be like uh there's nothing here no
new facts it's it's what everyone
already knew and their brag is doing it
anyway so I gotta say like okay you know
maybe maybe we'll end up sitting back
and what's really happening is this
of a D.A steps out from a local
office and embarrasses the Democratic
party nationally and Trump is playing
the game because he knows every step of
the way it's humiliating to them yeah it
is it's it's really something to see man
and you know like as I said before even
as a sharp critic of of Donald Trump for
other reasons not like the stupid ones
um but this is just look the guy was
just objectively this is a guy who was
as sitting president framed for treason
like framed for treason by his own deep
State there's a real deal attempted coup
they all knew he was not involved in a
conspiracy with Russia nobody at the CIA
or the FBI actually believe that none of
them believed Carter page was a Russian
agent
the CIA told the FBI that he was an
informant for the CIA and then the FBI
uh said on their fisa Court application
that the CIA corroborated that he had
talked to the Russians but they left out
the part that then he came right back to
the CIA and informed them of this so
this is it is I don't know for sure if
this Sorrows backed uh D.A is like in on
some Grand conspiracy he might be but
there is no question that what Donald
Trump laid out in his speech last night
is exactly right that they've tried at
every single turn to get him for the
most ridiculous things and like probably
like Phil like I'd be fine if they
wanted to get him for any of his real
crimes that he did commit like all
presidents commit like real it
violations of international law illegal
bombing of Syria illegally starving the
people of Yemen fine charge him for that
I'll cheer if you do the problem is that
that would implicate Joe Biden and
Barack Obama and Bill Clinton and George
Bush and Dick Cheney and so they're not
going to do that and so they got to go
after him for this stuff I think they
should uh
I think they should I mean you know they
indicted Trump and it's it's fair game
now so what I said the other day is that
any conservative D.A in Colorado or san
or the San Diego area wherever Abdul
Rahman al-alalaki lived should there's
no statute of limitations on murder so
they could they could indict Barack
Obama for the murder of Abdul Rahman
al-alaki or even Anwar alaki for that
matter who was his father who look he
did he he was radicalized and he swore
allegiance to Al Qaeda but when you're
an American citizen
you have to be charged with a crime and
then you have to be convicted of that
crime you don't get to just say this guy
said he's with them so I murdered him
and and the one that's more damning
about Anwar Lucky in a way even then his
his was his kid 14 at the time 16 16. oh
yeah I think 16. um but the one that's
more damning you know in a sense is that
they admitted that he was the target so
they try to pretend that the kid wasn't
the target but they admit that Anwar
alaki was the target of that strike so
Barack Obama murdered an American
citizen with no charges Barack Obama
murdered an American citizen and he got
no charges and the Deep state turns
their head and all the time I would love
to have you talk with Destiny the Omni
liberal because you know what his
response was when he was here he was
like well he's the president he has
great deference when it comes to war and
I was like not telling Americans in
countries we are not at war with by what
standard does he have this like like
what are you talking about according to
the United States uh Constitution
since World War II right so all these
military authorizations are completely
unconstitutional and then there's also
international law which says you can't
just bomb Sovereign countries can we
just go back a second because you said
something I think was important
isn't it amazing that the Deep State and
the Democrats framed our democratically
elected president as a traitor and
foreign agent they they framed him as
this and it's like that is the normal
course of action now for this country
that that's crazy well I mean look they
framed a sitting president well say I
mean they also blew one's brains out on
National Television so it's not like
well talking about the president Carlson
comes out and he's like didn't he
basically come out and say JFK was
assassinated but yeah by the CIA or
whatever yeah he said a guy
um uh who you know an anonymous source
who had seen firsthand all the redacted
uh documents basically confirmed it to
him now do with that what you will but
there's a I mean you could go down that
rabbit hole there's a lot there I'll
also say the Nixon thing really stinks
if you look into it like what was it I
think uh two of the four people who
broke into Watergate were like CIA
connected just saying there's a lot of
shady stuff in the past but what's
really interesting about Donald Trump is
that Donald Trump although I will
criticize him for not following through
with a lot of his rhetoric that was
pretty good on some of this stuff Donald
Trump was the first presidential
candidate or I should say the first
successful presidential candidate who
won in any of our lifetime times who ran
unapologetically in opposition to the
Deep State yeah I mean like he ran
saying that like we were lied into war
in Iraq saying that Obama created Isis
saying all of these things that were
kind of true I mean Obama certainly
funded Isis
um and and so he made enemies of the
deep state in a way that none of these
other presidents have when I remember
watching the uh debates when Trump told
uh who did he tell Jeb Bush or whatever
when he was like your brother lied I
said to war or something like that South
Carolina I was like
whoa it was pretty pretty unreal that
moment of standing in front of South
Carolina Republicans at the primary
debate and telling the whole crowd that
the last Republican president not like
led us into a bad war or something like
that lied us into a war where a million
people died like basically saying he he
should be you know like arrested or
whatever and I remember that day all the
pundits were like well he blew it yeah I
mean he really looked that ain't gonna
play in South Carolina and the next day
was the South Carolina primary Donald
Trump took 60 percent of the vote and
the other 11 split Authority amongst
themselves wow it's so amazing yeah well
so uh so you're you're now the a a Maga
Trump supporter all the way now I hear I
I said he should be convicted for war
crimes I'm just saying get all of them
but you shouldn't be convicted for
paying off a hooker and not itemizing it
on his taxes amazing that's what it is
yeah
they're they're they're they're
claiming that uh this is this is what's
funny
uh is imagine you you uh Dave have a
carpenter buddy who is uh remodeling
your garage
and it's an attached to garage so you
know you want to put like a loft and
second floor of it or something and uh
he goes to the store and he buys
burglars tools and he Robs a jewelry
store and then uh he sends you a bill
for the construction in your garage and
it just itemized as construction and you
pay it and then one day the feds come to
your house and say you are actually
buying in burglars tools and you're like
what what you've got a payment here that
went right to him you were paying him
every month and you were like yeah he's
a carpenter in my garage like my buddy
stools that's the Trump indictment
Michael Cohen according to his own
lawyers paid Stormy Daniels of his own
volition with no reimbursement out of
his own pocket Donald Trump was paying
legal bills to Michael Cohen and they
just decided Bragg says he was probably
reimbursing him we just say that and
it's even weaker than than uh your
analogy because there's no actual crime
committed to it like it's not a crime to
pay someone to not talk about something
like to come to an agreement with
someone if I give you this money you
won't talk about it there's no crime and
it's not a campaign Finance violation
the reason why he hasn't been tried
federally is because there's already
president for this with John Edwards or
they tried to say that oh you paying off
your side piece is a campaign Finance
violation the problem is that the logic
of that is like oh it would have hurt
your campaign so therefore it's a
campaign Finance you know or a campaign
but the the problem with that is that
there's also lots of other non-campaign
related reasons why you might want to
like he might just not want his wife to
find out right and you can't say you
can't say anything that would make you
look bad is a campaign expense or any
otherwise anything that makes you look
good should be a campaign expense too
right you should be able to charge your
campaign for a new convertible because
you're like I look good when I drive
this the whole thing that makes most
sense yeah did you watch album bags uh
press conference you got pressed by
these reporters saying you know your
predecessor wouldn't prosecute this this
has been thrown out a couple different
times why are you moving forward with it
and he didn't really have any answer to
that he was just like well
uh he's committed crimes 34 of them I
guess like there was no explanation
because there's not one yeah it was it
was asked by a reporter in order for
this to be elevated to a felony there
has to be an underlying crime what is
that crime and why didn't you include it
he goes the law does not require me to
which is not true the law that he is
invoking says you can't that it's a
crime to um to lie on your business
records in service of another crime so
there it has to be connected to another
crime he's just like trying to play this
he's arguing it is but it doesn't say
there that I have to tell you what that
crime is right right so that I mean it's
just so freaking absurd and then the
sixth amendment basically says we have a
right to as I confront our accusers and
understand the charges and a speedy
trial and all that Jess so uh not now
the Bragg's courtroom he says None
that's why that's why I've just been
saying like
I mean I should have been saying this
years ago when they as you pointed out
framed our democratically elected
president as a foreign agent and and
traitor to this country uh perhaps I
should have been saying the country
ended in 2016. yeah I mean I'd go 1913
but sure wherever you want to start it
creation of the Federal Reserve uh but I
um I'll say that it's even to me who's
like you know I'm pretty against this
entire establishment against every inch
of the U.S federal government I thought
I was I was surprised that they crossed
the line once he was President I thought
it was a crazy line to cross to frame
the presidential candidate Donald Trump
for treason but when they actually you
had them doing it to the sitting
president uh even to me I was like wow
they're actually going to do this to
this guy and look they didn't they they
didn't remove him from office they
floated around that idea and in fact um
Andrew McCabe who I believe was the
number three at the justice department
he talked about this in his 60s Minutes
interview where he says before they they
suck Robert Mueller on Donald Trump they
all in the Department of Justice in the
FBI debated invoking the 25th Amendment
they were like maybe we could just
remove he like says this you can go find
his words on camera says that they
thought about well we could just remove
him but instead we'll just stick this uh
special prosecutor on him and that and
so they didn't they didn't remove them
but they did box him in and they box at
what Donald Trump ran on in 2016 was
that we should have detaunt with Russia
that we should get along with Russia we
should stop trying to overthrow Bashar
al-assad and Syria we should work with
Russia to fight Isis there because we
both have a mutual interest there and
why not get along with Russia why not
move in this direction of being friends
and man so because they were accusing
him of being a Russian agent every day
on TV he could never make a deal with
Russia because then that would have been
seen as like oh look proof he clearly is
a Russian agent so then he Donald Trump
because he's
not Ron Paul and not the great president
he was supposed to be uh he went out of
his way to prove how anti-russia he was
so he goes I'm not a Russian agent I'll
show you right now I'll tear up the IMF
treaty I'll draw I'll send weapons into
Ukraine I'll do everything to show you
how much of a hawk I am on Russia so
they it actually did work in a sense
where they boxed him into taking the
wrong position and man if he had been
able to do what he was running on we
wouldn't be in the disaster in Ukraine
we are today there'd be a hundred
thousand people who would still have
their lives
I agree
yeah what do you think about uh the
upcoming election you're gonna you're
gonna vote Trump no
uh you know do you think you'll vote
libertarian I think there's a strong
chance there's a strong chance that I
could vote Liberty we got to see who uh
the candidate is
so I mean there's so many great options
I mean yeah that guy that guy gets up
there I'm obviously libertarian oh yeah
well running around his living room in
his boxers Democrat though I think he
runs he runs as a Democrat no he's been
probably dragging down the libertarian
party for the past now those days are
over it's a new libertarian party now
what are you guys Fielding that I want
to know well we've got a lot of great
candidates that's very non-specific I'll
answer Alvin Bragg that's the most
specific I can give you I don't have to
give you a crime I don't need to give
you I can't tell you anything
um but I will say no I wouldn't I'm I'm
interested I will say that Donald
Trump's rhetoric over the last say
couple months has been the best he's
been since at least 2016. yeah the stuff
he's been saying on the Ukraine war has
been spot on now that's a big difference
between me actually trusting him he said
some good things in 2016 and then he's
putting John Bolton as his National
Security advisor so that's it's one
thing to say it but I will say ma'am the
other day uh when he he had that uh
Speech or whatever where he said he was
like the number one enemy for America is
not Russia the number one enemy is and I
was just so sure he was going to say
China and I was already rolling my eyes
I was like preemptively rolling my eyes
at him saying China and then he went the
number one enemy is the Deep State and
Washington DC and all of this and I just
I felt myself standing to clap
I fought it but I felt myself standing
in a platform so there's a lot better to
see I'm talking like this then talking
about how he saved a million people's
lives because he had he invented the
vaccine or whatever but you know you
know that he's like he's definitely
gonna be like there after me so he's
gonna sit there and attack the Deep
State and if he wants to go after the
bureaucracy more like for this entire
time that he's running more power to him
attack them show you show as much she'll
show as much of the bad stuff they do
make it you know shines much light as
you can you know
um I just you know he had the chance to
do something about it and he didn't I
just think he has some fire back right
now like when he announced in November I
didn't feel it the way that you know
obviously the iconic escalator moment
and you know with East Palestine with
some of his rhetoric it seems like he
has got his momentum back in a way that
is truly terrifying to other candidates
you can't really compete with Donald
Trump when he is ready to spar with you
and it's really me put him in a fighting
position of late yeah well look and this
fuels some conspiracy theories uh too
which I I don't know if there's any
truth to any of them but there there is
no question to me that it really helps
Donald Trump with his base when they
raid his home in Mar-A-Lago and when
they bring these nonsense charges to him
because it does again make him kind of
like it gives you this narrative that of
course as we were saying is based off a
lot of truth that he has been completely
targeted but like he won the election in
2016 and he never got a chance to
actually be president of the United
States thanks for watching this clip
from the timcast IRL podcast hang out
with us live Monday through Friday at 8
pm and become a member over at
timcast.com for uncensored members only
shows exclusive
thanks for hanging out and we'll see you
all next time